[Música]
a ver decidme quién no ha soñado alguna
vez con un crucero por las islas griegas
por mykonos santorini rodas o por las
más de 1000 islas que grecia tiene
repartidas en el eje o hablamos casi del
paraíso de los campos elíseos del
turista pre cobit que mortal podría
resistirse a un viaje así pues lo cierto
es que sólo se me ocurre uno recep tayip
erdogán amigos este montón de islas
griegas del mar egeo se ha convertido en
una pesadilla para los planes del
presidente turco y en atenas son
perfectamente conscientes de ello y
claro después deberá llamar acaso ya
liam neeson pues ya se sabe pocas bromas
con estambul precisamente por eso en
este vídeo vamos a ver cómo se está
preparando grecia ante lo que pueda
ocurrir preparados pues arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
recientemente el vez y turquía han sido
noticia por un terremoto pero queridos
amigos de visual política y 8 que se
entra en cara ya tendrás hace tiempo que
van más allá de los sísmicos por ejemplo
el último choque relevante ha sido a
cuenta de lo que está aconteciendo en el
mediterráneo oriental donde bajo el mar
en el subsuelo se ha encontrado gas
natural una materia prima a la que
erdogán no está dispuesta a renunciar ni
a un solo metro cúbico pero claro la
cuestión es determinar si realmente le
corresponde o no a turquía explotar los
yacimientos encontrados y la verdad es
que constante isla griega de por medio
por no hablar ya de chipre pues digamos
que en principio el derecho marítimo no
parece dejarles muchas opciones a los
otros manos la propia unión europea ha
hecho una sutil defensa de las fronteras
marítimas de sus miembros algo que quedó
hasta erdogán no está dispuesto a
aceptar para turquía
un kilómetro ha de ser end and grill de
aeronaves set de griezmann access de
nadal existente el equipo decide sigue
sin dejarle tienen alcohol and act en
ese incendio
ya va a ser también modelo 2010 y
licorne
la isla a la que se refiere el dog danés
kastelorizo es la isla griega habitada
más oriental
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea se sitúa a
más de 500 kilómetros de gràcia
continental pero está a apenas 2 km de
turquía y aunque se refiere a esta isla
lo cierto es que podría referirse
prácticamente a cualquier otra porque lo
cierto es que en el mar egeo de las más
de 100 islas que hay habitadas sólo dos
pertenecen a turquía hablamos de islas
que con el derecho marítimo
internacional en la mano pues para
intentar la grecia los derechos de
explotación de los recursos del subsuelo
lo que excluye a sus vecinos turcos con
semejante panorama y sabiendo lo que
sabemos del presidente turco pues no
parece que erdogán vaya a quedarse
quieto no nos parece pues amigos y
latinas tienen exactamente la misma
impresión por lo que ya se están
poniendo las pilas y preparándose
incluso para el peor de los escenarios
un enfrentamiento directo porque aunque
pueda llegar a parecernos ciencia
ficción o un desenlace de los
acontecimientos altamente improbable
grecia está dispuesta a defender lo que
considera suyo pero vale sabemos que el
ejército turco es uno de los más grandes
de todo el mundo ahora bien que sabemos
del ejército griego pues que las cosas
cambian un poco desde leónidas
la llegada de donald trump a la
presidencia de eeuu puso sobre la mesa
de la otan la exigencia de que sus
miembros alcanzaron un gasto militar de
un 2% de su pib en acción al solo 10 de
los 30 países de la alianza atlántica
cumplen este objetivo y en este ranking
grecia alcanza un sorprendente segundo
puesto justo tras eeuu el problema es
que grecia también es en proporción el
país que más destina de su gasto militar
a pagar a su personal al menos si los
griegos siguen siendo 300 parece que
están bien pagados de todos modos lo que
ocurre en grecia es muy interesante por
un lado se gasta la pasta en personal y
por otro las partidas sobrantes que
puede dedicar al equipamiento militar
las destina a defenderse de turquía u
otro país de la otan menudo galimatías
ahora bien porque tanto resentimiento
entre griegos y turcos está acaso
preparada grecia para defenderse de
turquía y tal vez la pregunta más
importante de todas puede hacer frente a
la economía griega la presión que
entrañaría un posible conflicto amigos
hoy en visual político vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos
a ver un poco de historia
el tratado de lausana
son muchas las cosas que separan a
grecia turquía más allá del giro y es
que no se trata simplemente de una
frontera entre dos países no es una
frontera que separa dos continentes dos
religiones dos civilizaciones oriente y
occidente una frontera castigada por
siglos y siglos de enfrentamientos una
frontera amigos que desde la guerra de
troya ha sido un no parar desde
alejandro magno o bizancio hasta los
turcos otomanos de hecho los actuales
problemas entre atenas y estambul
obedecen a cuestiones que se remontan un
siglo atrás en el tiempo hasta justo
después de la primera guerra mundial una
guerra que fue un completo desastre para
el imperio otomano
[Música]
derrotado en la guerra el sultán estaba
dispuesto a aceptar el tratado de sèvres
un tratado con concesiones difíciles de
digerir como por ejemplo que parte de
anatolia quedara ocupada por grecia de
esta forma a los nacionalistas turcos
liderados por mustafa kemal atatürk se
levantaron en armas y expulsaron a los
griegos del sultán la nueva república
turca negoció entonces 1 acuerdo el
tratado de lausana un tratado que supuso
para grecia renuncia a la traza oriental
a dos islas de elegido frente al
estrecho de dardanelos que esos
intereses en asia menor a cambio turquía
renunciaba a chipre y otros posibles
intereses en el mar egeo como por
ejemplo a las islas del dodecaneso
pues bien el caso es que el tratado de
lausana es actualmente casi 100 años
después de su firma la causa de los
principales tensiones entre grecia y
turquía y es que veréis son tres las
cosas que han pasado desde entonces que
han roto el equilibrio pactado fijaos
para empezar las islas del dodecaneso
que eran de italia cuando se firmó el
tratado pasaron a ser villegas tras la
derrota italiana en la segunda guerra
mundial en segundo lugar a islotes que
no quedaron mencionados expresamente en
el tratado de lausana pero que
geográficamente hablando pertenecen al
archipiélago del dodecaneso se entiende
por tanto que son griegos pero sin
embargo los turcos los reivindican como
suyos y luego por último el tratado fijo
las aguas territoriales para las islas
del egeo en tres millas más tarde grecia
las amplió hasta las seis millas sin
malestar aparente de turquía pero lo que
nadie podía saber entonces es que a
finales del siglo 20 el derecho
internacional comúnmente aceptado
ampliaría el mar territorial hasta las
12 millas
pero espera hace un momento porque para
entonces las tropas de ambos países ya
se habían batido en un enfrentamiento
directo el campo de batalla fue la isla
de chipre un país independiente de donde
gobernaba la mayoría grecochipriota pero
donde había una notable comunidad turca
el caso es que en 1974 turquía invadió
su tercio norte instauró la república
turca del norte de chipre que como ya os
contamos no tiene reconocimiento
internacional y si regresamos al eje o
el choque más grave entre griegos y
turcos tuvo lugar en 1996 por inia un
islote deshabitado próximo al
archipiélago del dodecaneso y amigos el
detonante de este conflicto no tiene
desperdicio
en la navidad de 1995 un barco turco en
cayo ante el islote de limia y renunció
a la ayuda de grecia alegando que era
territorio turco semanas después acudió
un político griego al islote y colocó
una bandera lena en venganza a unos
periodistas turcos del hürriyet fueron
al islote y la reemplazaron por la turca
finalmente atenas envió a nueve soldados
griegos acamparon en el islote y
restituyeron la bandera griega la
presencia militar griega puso en pie de
guerra amiri a armada turca y los
griegos no tardaron en hacer lo mismo
que estuvo a punto de declararse en la
guerra pero eeuu intermedio para que se
restableciera la calma
[Música]
bueno llegados a este punto o
simplemente os preguntaréis por qué
demonios de adif y turquía se están
peleando en 2020 pues bien la cuestión
es que turquía es una de la veintena de
países quien no ha firmado la convención
de las naciones unidas que regula el
derecho internacional del mar desde 1994
por ese motivo encara no acepta el
artículo del tratado que dice que las
islas así como la tierra firme tienen
plataforma continental algo muy
importante para la explotación de los
recursos económicos ya que ankara
reivindica que las islas griegas
cercanas a la costa turca carecen de
plataforma propia de esta forma según
esta visión la zona de influencia griega
sobre el ejido empezaría en la grecia
continental y la zona de influencia
turca en el mar no estaría limitada por
las islas griegas vamos que el gas
natural sería de los turcos por otra
parte aunque turquía acepta el límite de
12 millas de las aguas territoriales
para todos los países hace una excepción
con grecia y ojo porque estas dos
semillas han vuelto a protagonizar
titulares en 2020 entre otras cosas
porque en agosto grecia decidió ampliar
a 12 millas sus aguas territoriales en
el mar jónico que comparte con italia y
no sólo eso sino que atenas no dudó en
asegurar que pronto haría lo mismo con
el eje o por supuesto la reacción turca
fue
turquía advierte de que la decisión de
grecia de extender sus aguas
territoriales en el egeo es causa de
guerra de momento esto no se ha
producido pero la situación es más
complicada de lo que parece a simple
vista
[Música]
el centroderecha de nueva democracia
recuperó el poder en grecia a mediados
de 2019 pero en buena medida louis a
costa de alimentar una agenda
nacionalista con la que poder competir
con la extrema derecha de amanecer
dorado la estrategia ha sido exitosa
pero quería cause mitsotakis el primer
ministro es ahora rehén de una facción
nacionalista de nueva democracia con
suficientes diputados como para derrocar
a su gobierno
por otra parte todos conocemos al
presidente turco erdogán ha sido tajante
asegura que no permitirá bajo ningún
concepto que el eje no se convierta en
un lago griego alcalá considera que si
grecia extendiera sus aguas
jurisdiccionales hasta las 12 millas
pues turquía habría libertad a su
libertad de navegación en este mapa por
ejemplo podéis ver cómo cambiaría el
mapa político del mar egeo
la pregunta es cómo demonios se puede
solucionar todo esto
[Música]
pues el diálogo es complicado porque
atenas no ve necesidad de negociar nada
claro les va bien así consideran que
sentarse a hablar con turquía pues
implicaría hacer concesiones sin nada
que ganar así que el reto ahora para el
gobierno de miso takis es no dejarse
llevar por los nacionalistas a la hora
de responder a las provocaciones turcas
un momento de provocaciones que
provocaciones pues por ejemplo es
frecuente que aviones turcos invadan el
espacio aéreo griego y no sólo eso
recientemente turquía enviado al grup
reid un buque de exploración a hacer
prospecciones de gas y petróleo en las
inmediaciones de kastelórizo hablamos de
un área que grecia considera como su
zona económica exclusiva de hecho hace
unos meses el choque de una fragata
griega contra una fragata turca que
escoltaba a los rays volvió a poner la
tensión por las nubes y ojo porque no se
descarta que turquía que ha tomado la
iniciativa de forma unilateral en
escenarios como irak y siria podría
organizar una operación militar an cilia
sobre alguna isla del egeo y ante
semejante escenario la cuestión es en
qué situación se encuentra exactamente
el ejército griego puede acaso disuadir
a los turcos cómo podría reaccionar ante
un posible ataque atentos
[Música]
esto es esparta si estuvieras al frente
de grecia probablemente lo primero que
os preguntaréis es cómo puede golpearnos
turquía al final que abordo ganado para
una doctrina conocida como la patria
azul una doctrina por la cual turquía
reivindica el control de las aguas del
este del egeo y el norte del
mediterráneo hablando por tanto los
derechos que generan todas las islas
griegas como os podéis imaginar este
mapa pues no tiene ninguna validez a
nivel internacional sólo vale si estás
en turquía o tal vez en un kebab pero
amigos ni con un buen durum los turcos
han conseguido convencer a nadie más
claro que una mente eso no quita para
que legalmente encara sí que se guarde
un as en la manga me explico todas esas
islas griegas del este del egeo quedaron
desmilitarizadas con la convención de
montrose un acuerdo internacional de
1936 sin embargo grecia esgrime que
tiene motivos más que suficientes para
desconfiar de turquía desde que invadió
chipre hace más de 40 años vamos que ni
harto de raki dejarían indefensas a
algunas de sus islas así que a falta de
turistas este año numerosos efectivos
militares griegos se dejaron ver por
algunas de estas islas del egeo y claro
la protesta
pues no se hizo esperar turquía denuncia
que grecia colocó ilegalmente más tropas
en kastelorizo con este panorama parece
más que evidente donde podría
materializarse exactamente la amenaza
turca cualquier isla del este del eje o
bañada por aguas obras que encara
reivindica esa especie de patria azul y
amigos actualmente un enfrentamiento
entre grecia y turquía estaría marcado
por la clara superioridad turca tanto
numérica como tecnológica de hecho
tienen a su cuarto ejército estacionado
en esmirna equipado con capacidad aérea
y de desembarco y además está a punto de
contar con su primer porta helicópteros
desarrollado por la industria turca en
consorcio con quedaros con esto el
diseño de la empresa española navantía y
no sólo eso el ejército turco está
equipado también con armamento más
moderno y cuenta a su disposición con
una industria armamentística propia algo
de lo que grecia carece
[Música]
en cualquier caso aún así un
enfrentamiento a media escala sería más
equilibrado de lo que parece pero ya
lleva décadas esperando el movimiento
turco y cuenta con la ventaja de que el
territorio defender es muy reducido por
lo que la superioridad numérica turca no
tendría así tanta importancia claro que
lo peor para grecia podría ser que
erdogán apostará por un escenario de
hechos consumados una estrategia al
estilo putin si algo nos enseñó la
anexión de crimea es que la respuesta de
occidente a la conquista de un
territorio ya no es tan enérgica como
cabía esperar una operación relámpago de
turquía para hacerse con una isla como
kastelorizo situada a un par de
kilómetros de la costa turca y con una
población de apenas 500 personas
otorgaría erdogán una baza con la que
forzar una negociación sobre sus
derechos marítimos en el egeo y el
mediterráneo pues bien para evitar esta
situación gracias está organizado una
defensa espartana de sus islas eso es de
hecho lo que explica los movimientos de
tropas denunciados por turquía también
se han puesto las pilas para modernizar
su ejército el gobierno griego amigos
está aprovechando todas las
oportunidades que se le ponen por
delante la más evidente podemos verla
con todo lo que ha pasado con los cazas
más modernos del mundo los efectos
e
veréis me explico turquía ha sido un
estrecho aliado de los estados unidos
desde la guerra fría pero claro ni a la
otan ni a la casa blanca les gustó un
pelo que erdogán decidiera comprar la
reducida del sistema de defensa aérea s
400 y es que claro no parece una buena
idea entregar uno de los mejores aviones
de combate a alguien que trabaja codo
con codo con los técnicos que diseñan
los misiles que deberían abatir los así
que en atenas y en washington
rápidamente vieron el business sin
gracia recibir a sis aviones f-35 de
eeuu que estaban programados para
turquía y no sólo eso grecia desplegado
también sus mejores artes diplomáticas
para formar una especie de bloque frente
a turquía que engloba a países como
egipto con el que ha cerrado un acuerdo
de demarcación marítima o emiratos
árabes unidos- que recela de los bajos y
turquía con su archienemigo qatar
también realiza maniobras militares con
países como chipre israel que a su vez
también chocan con turquía por el
control del gas del mediterráneo y se ha
tomado muy pero que muy en serio lo de
encandilar a francia e italia dos países
muy influyentes que podrían llegado el
caso a arrastrar a toda la unión europea
a plantar cara a erdogán macro aun por
ejemplo ya ha mostrado una firme
oposición al presidente turco bien sea
por convicción o por lo que más le gusta
a los políticos
el business compra griega de aviones de
combate de fabricación francesa por
valor de dos mil millones de euros si lo
habéis escuchado bien una factura de
2.000 millones de euros para grecia mil
700 millones de euros por 18 aviones
rafael y otros 300 millones en armamento
y aquí aquí no acaba el asunto y en
alemania viven casi 4 millones de
personas de origen turco que
precisamente por este motivo berlín es
muy suave con erdogán pues parece que el
próximo encargo griego será de cuatro
fragatas a berlín ahora bien en el
momento esperado esperad allí algo que
llama la atención tanto han cambiado las
cosas en grecia como para poder soportar
tantos gastos en equipos militares
atentos
del dracma al drama
[Música]
desde que greg se convirtió en miembro
fundador del euro a nivel económico no
ha dado más que disgustos se gastaron
hasta el último drama en organizar los
juegos olímpicos y desde entonces bueno
desde entonces digamos que ha vivido
casi siempre afrontando su penúltima
crisis durante años las palabras troika
y rescate se asociaron más con grecia
que el mismísimo yogur no obstante desde
entonces la situación ha mejorado
bastante todo hay que decirlo- los
títulos griegos de deuda pública a diez
años ofrecen un rendimiento del 0 68 por
ciento cuando en 2012 pues llegan hasta
cerca del 40 por ciento atenas ahora
pueden jugarse sin demasiados apuros
cuál es el problema entonces pues que el
coronavirus ha vuelto a disparar la
afición elena por el endeudamiento y por
tanto posiblemente la desconfianza de
los inversores y prevé que la deuda
pública alcance el 208 9% del pib en
2020 amigos grecia ha afrontado en
noviembre su segundo confinamiento a
nivel nacional la economía elena cada
este año más de un 10 por ciento y como
os podéis imaginar pues no sé no parece
el mejor momento para una aventura
bélica en la que atenas no tiene nada
que ganar
ah
no obstante el gasto militar de grecia
ha crecido un 10% desde el 2013 claro
que el gasto turco sigue siendo tres
veces superior por lo tanto aunque
quieran modernizar sus fuerzas armadas
estoy seguro seguro que en atenas nadie
quiere ver abatido en el eje o uno de
esas gafas que ha costado más de 100
millones de euros así que para evitar
este enfrentamiento la otan ha sido el
ámbito en el que de momento grecia
turquía han arreglado sus diferencias y
que mejor forma para una alianza surgida
de la guerra fría que proporcionarán una
solución en forma de bingo una línea
telefónica la otan asegura que grecia y
turquía establecieron una línea directa
para evitar enfrentamientos en el
mediterráneo oriental en fin ya lo veis
parece que de momento las aguas se han
calmado en el eje oa ninguna de las dos
partes les conviene seguir avivando la
tensión y un enfrentamiento pues
probablemente no compensaría ningún
beneficio potencial que se pudiera
llegar a obtener pero claro cuando uno
de los jugadores erdogán pues cualquier
cosa puede ocurrir en fin lo que pueda
pasar ya os lo hemos contado ahora en
visual política estaremos muy atentos al
cuando pero de momento turno para ti
crees que a veces está dando los pasos
correctos a nivel diplomático y militar
para resistir una posible ofensiva turca
crees que tiene sentido que a pesar de
su mala situación financiera el gobierno
griego siga gastando
así más en armas eres más fan del yogur
griego o del que amigos déjanos tu
respuesta que bajo en los comentarios y
ya sabéis si este vídeo se resultó
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like suscribiros abisal político una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo hasta la próxima
[Música]